hey 42 here don't wear a mask
wear a mask don't wear a mask no wait
do wear one at all times except
here here and maybe there
the advice around wearing face masks to
reduce a spread of covert 19
coming from some governments large ngos
and igos
has been at best confusing and the worst
outright contradictory that's why i want
to dive deep into the science behind
wearing masks
to bust some common myths and answer two
simple questions
does wearing a face mask reduce the
spread of covert 90
and is it something we should all be
doing right now
well to sort of answer the second
question
i'm not going to tell you whether or not
you should wear a mask it isn't my place
to do so
you are hopefully a responsible person
and i'm sure you'll assess the science
way up all the advice from various
sources
and come to your own conclusion based on
your unique circumstances
but how can you even begin to make that
call without clear
science-backed information instructing
the general population to wear a face
mask has never been a popular decision
even when it is ostensibly for the
greater good
in 1918 towards the end of world war one
the spanish flu
now known to have been the h1n1
influenza virus
swept across the world infecting one
third of the global population and
killing up to an estimated 50 million
people
during the height of the pandemic
governments around the globe introduced
restrictive measures to curb the spread
of the killer virus
especially to protect frontline troops
from falling ill
all the way from no spitting rules and
closing schools to yes you guessed it
mandating the wearing of face masks
most people an estimated 80 percent
complied with the
mask wearing mandate but there were
rebellious splinter groups such as the
imaginatively named anti-mask league
that formed in san francisco
who outright refused to don one citing
their discomfort
and restriction on breathing some people
also felt that masks made day-to-day
business
awkward and unprofessional but
how did this mask mask wearing
experiment
play out did it have any effect on
quelling the spanish flu's virulence or
slowing its spread not really
this graph shows the results of a study
published in 1919 by the california
state department of health
comparing weekly death rates per 100 000
people
in stockton where the wearing of masks
was made compulsory
and boston where it wasn't
as you can see there's little to no
difference between the curves
however there's more to this data than
meets the eye
and with our now greater understanding
of epidemiology and the benefit of
hindsight
there are some vital lessons to be
learnt from this story
that we can apply to our current
situation to help us kick the crap out
of covert
firstly the masks that were most
commonly worn during the spanish flu
were made of gauze advanced respirators
and even basic surgical masks
typically three layers of polypropylene
sandwiched between
non-woven fabric were a distant
invention of the future
gauze on the other hand is well
a thin fabric mesh full of holes so
large they are easily visible to the
naked eye
that instantly puts a huge
droplet-shaped hole in what conclusions
we can draw from this data
to make mata's worse basic education for
the general public on how to wear a mask
including not touching it and keeping it
dry
was practically non-existent at least
outside of medical environments
and as we'll soon discover how you wear
a mask
is far more important than whether or
not
you wear one because incorrect usage can
actually
increase your likelihood of catching and
spreading a virus
michael mina is assistant professor of
epidemiology
at harvard t.h chan school of public
health
and a core member of the center for
communicable disease dynamics
he is joining us from the forum at
harvardchan
i asked michael why he thinks masks
weren't all that effective
during the spanish flu i would say it's
pretty hard to compare
1918 with today both from the quality of
the masks but also
i haven't seen particularly compelling
evidence
anyway of just how
just how reliably people are actually
wearing them
so fast forward to our current situation
as far as we know
this coronavirus sars cov2
which causes the disease called covid19
spreads primarily through respiratory
droplets which can be projected as far
as eight meters through coughing and
sneezing
but surely if i touch a droplet from an
infected individual that's landed on a
surface
and then touch my face the chance of me
catching covert is still
fairly low right this is called
fomite transmission and provided the
droplet which is now on your hand makes
contact with a mucous membrane
such as your eyes the inside of your
nose and mouth
you just put yourself at considerable
risk
because it's estimated that each droplet
contains
thousands of coronavirus particles known
as
virions when outside the body and
theoretically all it takes is one virion
to enter your system
evade your biological defenses and bind
with one of your respiratory cells
receptors to cause infection although in
the real world it will usually take
a lot more than just one virus particle
to cause infection
you may be thinking that you rarely if
ever
touch your face but you probably do so
much more than you realize because it's
an action that's often
autonomic meaning you're not consciously
aware
you're doing it a 2015 study in the
american journal of infection control
found that participants touched their
face an average
of 23 times per hour and 44
of those touches were on mucous
membranes
but subconsciously prodding your mucous
membranes may not even be required in
the first place
one study demonstrated how smaller viral
particles called
aerosols can remain suspended in the air
for around 14 minutes in laboratory
conditions
though this time would vary wildly in
the real world depending on atmospheric
conditions
certainly we have pretty good evidence
at this point that aerosolized
virus is a mode of transmission and
certainly within minutes
i i don't see any anything that would
imply that it uh
couldn't exist and i actually would
suggest that um given the right type of
super spreader who's maybe
really aerosolizing a lot due to some
some physiological differences that
maybe they have or just how
high the viral titer is in the
respiratory tract
i wouldn't be surprised if it's even
quite a bit longer than that
half hour you know the virus we know uh
does exist on us
on surfaces and uh and it can
similarly exist suspended in the air and
simply breathing in infected aerosols
may be enough
to cause infection and it's not just
those who are
obviously ill with covid19 coughing and
sneezing all over the place who are
spreading it
as you may have heard people who test
positive for covid
can be asymptomatic we're still
unsure about what percentage of those
with the disease
are asymptomatic but studies have
estimated
anywhere from 18 to 80 percent
quite the range i know i asked michael
mina what his take is on this
my guess is probably at least 50 percent
of people are
for all intents and purposes uh
asymptomatic and i wouldn't be surprised
if
in terms of the number of people who
recognize that they have been
infected by the time that they're
actually transmitting
uh without kind of looking back and
saying oh yeah i might have been sick at
that point
uh maybe it is up around 70 or 80
percent who who just don't actually
recognize
that they're sick at the time that
they're able to transmit the virus
but the important takeaway is that
individuals who
are asymptomatic and pre-symptomatic
meaning they are
yet to show symptoms can still spread
this particular coronavirus
you may be wondering how that's even
possible
if they aren't coughing and sneezing
aerosols and droplets everywhere
it's a good question but it turns out
covered 19 has unique properties
that make this type of transmission a
lot more likely
it produces an unusually high number of
viral particles
in the upper viral tract that's the
mouth
nasal cavity pharynx and larynx
and these can very easily shed outside
of the body
simply by talking compared to seasonal
flu
research has found that covid19 is
expelled from the body
through talking at a much higher rate in
pre
and asymptomatic patients and every time
you talk
even quietly you're spraying thousands
of tiny droplets into the environment
around you
after all the act of talking is
essentially just expelling air through a
very damp
chamber full of saliva mucus and tiny
bits of your breakfast
and if you talk loudly or shout you can
propel these droplets just as far as a
cough
or sneeze potentially infecting many
others around you in a public space
but don't think you can just avoid
talking to people because as michael
mina explains
there are a couple of other ways that
asymptomatic people can spread covet 19.
it's not just from talking it could also
be from coughing a lot of times people
with covet have a dry cough so you could
have a cough there but in general it's
going to be one of those but it can even
just be breathing but
talking is um does create more of a
of an expulsion of sort of a high energy
wave out of you so it's fairly
self-evident that wearing a good face
mask
can reduce the expulsion of these tiny
aerosolized
virions and larger droplets and indeed
using nifty camera tricks a few studies
have been able to demonstrate
just how great face masks are at almost
entirely eliminating
droplet expulsion and the formation of
aerosols
as shown here by this brilliant footage
captured by the university of new south
wales in sydney
and since we don't yet know what
percentage of people
are asymptomatic and the very nature
of being pre or asymptomatic means that
neither you nor anyone around you can
identify if you actually have covert 19
wearing a face mask seems like a really
sensible precaution
by simply wearing a mask in public you
vastly reduce the likelihood that you'll
infect those around you if you happen to
have covered
but not realize it don't believe me
one man traveling from china to toronto
had a dry cough the entire flight
and tested positive for covered 19 after
he landed
thankfully he had been wearing a face
mask during the journey
the result all 25 people
sitting closest to him on the flight
tested
negative for covert 19 afterwards
there are many other such examples to
name just one
two hairstylists in missouri who were
ill with covert 19
but wore face masks interacted with and
cut the hair of 139 clients
whilst they were real but when all of
those clients were tested
afterwards not one of them tested
positive for covert 19.
a very recent study from oxford
university published in late june
concluded that
yes when made of optimal materials which
we'll get into in just a moment
face masks are highly effective at
reducing the spread of covert 19.
however this effectiveness relies on
proper education on
and widespread adherence to correct mask
usage good hand hygiene and social
distancing
and this sort of consistent messaging is
not something we've seen up to now
which the study highlights as a
contributing factor as to why we've yet
to see any
irrefutable correlation between
widespread mass adoption
and lower transmission rates are numbers
but
people are beginning to pay attention
the percentage of americans now wearing
masks in public was up to 67
in july and around 84 of italians are
wearing them
despite neither of these two countries
having an established culture
of wearing face coverings no doubt
a lot more data will emerge over the
coming months
okay so we're fairly darn sure
that wearing a face mask can stop you
from spreading covet 19.
that's great but what you might want to
really know is whether wearing a mask
reduces the likelihood
of you catching it if some reprobate
coughs in my face when i'm wearing the
correct type of mask
will i get away virus free the truth is
we still don't know that yet what we can
quite confidently say is there is no
face covering that will guarantee you
won't catch any virus
even if you're ready to go full diving
helmet the only truly scientific way to
test whether masks protect the wearer as
well as those around them
would be to gather up a bunch of covered
positive people
and ask them to talk and cough directly
at two groups of people
in two separate rooms one group
who are wearing face masks and another
who are not for obvious reasons
that's not ethically possible and this
gap in our knowledge is probably a large
part of the reason you're seeing a lot
of mixed advice
on the efficacy of face masks as a means
of protection
all scientists can really do is look at
real world examples
and attempt to extrapolate correlations
something they
haven't been able to do conclusively
just yet
but to state the obvious having material
in front of one's nose and mouth
creates a physical barrier between your
mucous membranes
and the outside world that will very
likely filter out
at least some of those nasty virus
particles there's a long and storied
history of this in medical environments
and there's strong scientific data
supporting this
which is why ppe is so strictly mandated
in hospitals and
nursing homes this isn't just to reduce
onward transmission it's to protect the
well-being of those vital health workers
caring for people who are ill with covid
but compared to a full ppe kit which
includes a gown
n95 respirator goggles face shield and
rubber boots
your mileage is going to vary
significantly
even if you wear a decent face mask your
eyes are still an unguarded mucous
membrane on which tiny aerosolized virus
particles
can settle and infect you but don't
sweat
professor michael mina thinks that this
transmission vector through the eyes
is not something we should all be
getting worked up over
in real world environments i
don't know how much i subscribe to the
eyes being a major
form of transmission or acquisition i
think that it's probably
unlikely if you're immune compromised or
cancer or something like that then sure
wear goggles if
you know to give you excess protection
but my feeling is it's not going to be a
main mode of transmit or
acquisition put simply a face mask
offers the wearer a higher degree of
protection than not wearing one
even if we aren't entirely sure what
that degree
is yet but as we've learned from the
spanish flu
material matters if your face mask is
made of swiss cheese or is otherwise
porous
it's going to do very little in the way
of protecting you
and preventing you from passing on virus
particles to others
what may surprise you however is that
you don't need
medical grade face masks to help protect
others and yourself
any tightly woven cotton t-shirt
crudely cut out and fashioned into a
mask
preferably folded to create a double
layer will significantly reduce
your capacity for transmission in both
directions
don't want to chop up your precious iron
maiden 1981 tor
t-shirt fear not a recent study
conducted
at wake forest baptist medical center in
the u.s
suggested that some easily attainable
materials such as
heavyweight quilters cotton and even
vacuum cleaner bags preferably unused
provide fantastic protection filtering
out as many
as 79 of particles 0.3
to 1 microns in diameter the typical
size range of aerosolized virions
that's actually more than surgical masks
which the same study found to stop 62 to
of virus particles that's because
surgical masks can be more porous than
your typical
dense cotton fabric and don't protect
quite so well
against the smallest of aerial sliced
particles as they are
primarily designed to stop large
droplets
they're still a fantastic choice though
which you definitely shouldn't pass over
because keep in mind this study focused
on filtering the tiniest of virions
as we saw in the footage earlier
surgical masks are more effective at
filtering large droplets
than cloth masks on and so can offer
more
well-rounded protection lightweight
bandanas and scarves were amongst the
materials that provided the least
filtration power
and would not be widely recommended as a
suitable face covering
in fact a recent study by duke
university researcher martin fisher
found that using a neck fleece actually
increased transmission by an additional
10 percent
compared to wearing nothing at all a
bandana was found to make little to no
difference to filtration
the mass that offered the most
protection was of the n95 variety
which is not at all surprising its name
literally comes from the fact that it
filters out
95 of particles in this particular study
however
it felted 97 but before you rush out and
buy an n95 respirator
consider that they are currently in
extremely high demand
primarily by those on the front line
treating covert patients
they aren't easy to get hold of even if
you did manage to find a couple listed
in some
highly questionable rarely visited
corner of the internet
yeah a small tip here if your face mask
provider
also sells discounts dog food give it a
miss
even if they were easy to source what
have i told you
that you're still better off covering
your face with something like
a t-shirt surgical mask or any other
densely woven material instead
you see some variants of n95 respirators
especially those used in the
construction industry but some that are
used by medical professionals too
have an outlet valve on the front that's
designed to allow
unfiltered air to escape meaning that
they offer
little to no protection to those around
the wearer
many health professionals are strongly
advising against the use of this kind of
mask
because they are ineffective in reducing
the spread of covert 19.
the same goes for any other masks you
can purchase that feature an outlet
valve
like those cotton ones you've probably
seen popping up everywhere recently
far from protecting those around them
whereas if these kinds of masks are
essentially
exhaling highly targeted streams of
unfiltered air
potentially containing millions of
coronavirus particles and anyone who
happens to be nearby
that's why disney has wisely outright
bans the use of masks that contain a
valve in disney world theme parks
they've also specified that all masks
worn must contain at least two layers of
material
even more important than the kind of
mask you wear
is how you wear it a lot of governments
right now
are mandating the wearing of face masks
in indoor public spaces
but if most people are unsure of how to
wear masks properly or
simply refuse to follow the correct
procedures then
they may as well be walking around
licking lamp posts
and if that's how you roll anyway then i
strongly advise you to
put your weird hobby to bed until we're
no longer in a global pandemic
thanks like i said earlier wearing a
mask incorrectly
can put you and others around you at
higher risk of catching this coronavirus
than not wearing one at all and i know
it can be frustrating when you see
people wearing masks incorrectly
and for example grabbing the front of
their mask and rearranging it every two
minutes
but here's a quick fire checklist of
some really solid mask hygiene practices
you can follow
so at least you can set a good example
wash your hands before pushing on and
removing your mask
only put on your mask by touching the
ear straps
and pulling it over the ears so it's
snug and secure
if the mask has a metal strip at the top
pinch it
to create a better seal around the nose
never touch the material part of the
mask
after you've put it on especially when
in public
because it could be saturated with
coronavirus particles
that will then be on your fingers and
could lead to formide transmission
to yourself or others if
it helps you remember pretend that the
material part of your mask is made out
of lava
and if you touch it your hand will turn
into a lump of charcoal
if you do need to remove your mask in
public remove it by the ear straps only
and place it on a surface with the
outside or front side of the mask
facing down touching the surface make
sure
no surfaces come into contact with the
inside of your mask
if your mask gets damp or wet which can
happen after a few hours of use because
of your breath
you need to replace it with a fresh mask
or go home
and either discard it or wash it because
a damp mask offers significantly lower
protection
only remove your masks via the ear
straps
after you take your mask off either put
it in the washing machine
or dispose of it and then wash your
hands for at least 20 seconds with soap
and water
and of course there's the issue that
when people wear a mask
they may feel as though they instantly
become a quasi-coveted terminator
and are hence magically invulnerable to
the virus and get excessively cocky
engaging in behaviors that actually put
others at more risk
like ignoring social distancing or
attending large gatherings you know when
you're
casually comparing mangoes in the
supermarket and out of nowhere some guy
shoves his big
mask covered beak about two millimeters
from your face
to reach over and grab something well
don't be that guy just remember wearing
a mask is only one piece of a larger
puzzle in the fight to stem the spread
of this virus
it doesn't make social distancing or
good hand hygiene
any less important all of these elements
are needed
if we're going to slow this thing down
until there's an effective vaccine
or perhaps a fast and reliable
quantitative
home testing kit short of a vaccine
giving everyone a test that they can use
every single day that can tell them if
they're
transmitting the virus will essentially
create a semblance of herd immunity
and it could actually our calculations
suggest that it could very rapidly
cause the virus to be depleted out of a
population
if we had everyone or being able to use
or most people being able to use
a test for transmissibility every
morning or every other morning
that's all very well 42 but i've heard
that wearing a face mask can reduce
oxygen intake whilst increasing carbon
dioxide intake from your own exhalations
and can thus cause hypoxia or
hypercapnia
so that if you aren't careful you'll
keel over and
die like a strangled salmon well
if i may be blunt for a second this is
absolute rubbish
and no more than internet gossip and
fear-mongering
unless we're talking about young
children or those with pre-existing
breathing complications
there is no chance that wearing a simple
cotton or surgical mask will cut off
a sufficient quantity of your oxygen
intake to cause any ill effects
even if you do wear it all day long not
even n95 respirators
are known to cause hypoxia or
hypercapnia in healthy adults
surgeons all over the world have been
wearing them not to mention other
extremely tight and restrictive face
coverings
for decades now sometimes all day long
and we don't see mass die-offs of
surgeons on the headlines
it may feel like your breathing is
obstructed when you put on a mask
but that's most likely because mask
wearing is new to you
and you're not used to the sensation
because
yes obviously your breathing is
restricted a little with a mask
but there's simply no reputable evidence
that this is dangerous
in fit and healthy individuals of course
please do remove your mask if you start
to feel light-headed for any reason
so to summarize as far as we know the
main benefit of wearing a face mask
is not to protect yourself it's to
prevent you from passing coronavirus
particles to others
who may be more vulnerable than you or
who may pass it on to others who are
and i think in times like this it's nice
to go out of your way a little to be
caring and compassionate
to those in society who may not be as
fit and healthy as you and i
and because it's close to a certainty
that covert 19 spreads
pre and asymptomatically simply wearing
a mask
is a good way to do your bit to reduce
onwards transmission
and help put this frustrating chapter of
humanity behind us
so we can all stop wearing our pajamas
24 7.
because let's be honest they probably
needed a damn good wash after week one
of lockdown
and by now they might be harboring the
first stirrings
of the next global pandemic i'm just
trying to help shed some light on an
area that i think has been confusing for
a lot of people
thanks to the endless onslaught of
conflicting guidance from every angle
i know a lot of people have strong
opinions on wearing masks many of which
are understandable
so unless you're in a place where your
government has mandated the wearing of
one
which is soon to be most places anyway
whether you do wear a face mask
is ultimately your call to make but from
my point of view
mass mask adoption is almost certain to
save
some lives and any downsides are
at least for the vast majority of people
negligible
either way good luck out there and thank
you for watching
thank you to the team at google and
harvard t h
chan school of public health who helped
make this video possible
and especially dr michael mina phd
for his invaluable time and expertise